merci monsieur le Président d'abord au
nom du président Bruno Retailleau de
l'ensemble de notre groupe je veux
exprimer de nouveau ici notre solidarité
pleine et entière au peuple turc et
syrien et nous exprimons également notre
reconnaissance au secouriste français
partie en soutien c'est bien sûr notre
devoir mais c'est aussi madame la
Première ministre notre honneur
mesdames et messieurs les ministres vous
avez tous
île de route et des grands objectifs à
atteindre pour vous monsieur Bruno Le
Maire la réindustrialisation et de
belles gigafactory pour vous monsieur le
ministre Marc féno la souveraineté
alimentaire et donc la sauvegarde de
notaire agricoles pour vous monsieur le
ministre Clément bonne des nouvelles
lignes à grande vitesse des pistes
cyclables Canales et d'autres pour vous
Madame la Ministre Bérengère Couillard
la sauvegarde de la biodiversité et donc
naturellement la protection des espaces
naturels pour vous monsieur Klein les 13
ambitieux 400 000 logements
supplémentaires par an pour vous Madame
la Ministre Agnès panier rue naché
l’accélération des installations
d'énergie renouvelables et de centrales
nucléaires pour vous monsieur le garde
des sceaux la construction nouvelle
prison et c'est très bien et enfin pour
vous monsieur le ministre Béchu le
challenge lui répondre aux conclusions
de la modérément inspirée convention
citoyenne et l'atteinte du fameux 0
artificialisation nette mais au fond
mesdames et messieurs les ministres vous
rendez vous compte qu'au bout de
priorité en silo se trouve ceux qui
doivent appliquer tout cela en même
temps sur leur territoire c'est à dire
les élus locaux sur les mers il pleut
comme un Gravelotte des priorités toutes
prioritaires et des injonctions toutes
contradictoires pour lesquelles
d'ailleurs
[Applaudissements]
ils deviennent sanctionner aucune
planification territoriale ne devient
plus possible tant les priorités sont
nombreuses gouverner ses prévoir c'est
choisir ses priorités c'est donner un
cap alors madame la Première ministre
car c'est à vous que je pose cette
question je voudrais savoir dans
l'exécution des politiques publiques
quels sont vos priorités
[Applaudissements]